did you know that Esports has beef with
Crocs why the beef became very apparent
last year at Worlds when Riot delayed a
whole game because jooon decided he
wanted to get cozy basically Riot forbid
us wearing Crocs on stage they said that
we can either play with shoes or without
shoes but not with Crocs but the conflex
over Comfort hasn't stayed within the
borders of Le it's found its way to CS
as well with a Croc band being
explicitly mentioned in esl's landan
rule book that's right two of the
biggest Esports in the world are Waring
with Peak fashion now normally I would
suggest Anarchy to dismantle the system
since I can't wear my Shrek or Lightning
McQueen Crocs but instead I'm going to
offer players alternative options that
are technically in line you can pop some
melons while skating around in some
helies or better yet strut in some Astro
Boy shoes H you can even get yourself
some Poots AKA pant boots but for those
prone to restless legs why not invest in
some classic to shoes there you go I
just saved you from having to pay a fine
you're welcome